this is Kareem Davina speaking on the
behalf of Jean Luc psyche
what could a resonable for remake look
like that's the question on a lot of
fans minds after the report that Capcom
is planning on remaking resident before
the idea has left the internet a little
divided change on the one hand resonable
four is many people's personal favorite
and the prospect of it being lovingly
recreated in the beautiful ari engine
actually sounds pretty red I'll buy it
at a high price but for others resin
evil 4 is the pinnacle of the series and
as a result doesn't need to be remade
for any reason outside of it potentially
making a buttload of money no thanks
this is how I felt at first but the more
I think about it the more I realize how
boring would be to just remaster it with
no changes after all the RA 1 remake in
the RA to remake are two of my favorite
games so Capcom has proven that you can
make something great even better
so let's come up with some ideas for how
a game already as great as a Resident
Evil 4 could be even better ok for
starters
even though resin evil 4 is so beloved
there's actually one aspect that is
absolutely universally disliked hey take
it easy
no one likes Ashley well I didn't mind
her she does what I tell her to do and
she's very good at it
but she's a rather simple companion and
we've had a lot of excellent AI partners
and video games in the year since
lovable characters with complex
narratives and useful mechanics that
make you want them around Ashley well is
none of those things granted she's
helpless by design an objective you need
to protect but her complete lack of
self-preservation instinct feels archaic
and at its worst frustrates players
trying to keep her safe which leaves a
great opportunity to improve her in a
remake now I don't think you need to
give Ashley a gun but as an extra set of
eyes she could provide alerts to players
of incoming enemy ambushes she could
also inform Leon of nearby treasure or
maybe scavenge the loot enemies drop she
could even have an inventory slot that
can hold a single item of your choice
such as a spare health spray
which she can use on Liana in a tricky
situation by giving her small but
helpful things to do she could become
much less of a nuisance now when I think
of my favorite moments from Resident
Evil 4 I recall a terrifying opening
village sequence the first El Gigante
fights when you're assisted by an
adorable pup and the unexpected shift to
a gothic castle run by this guy I've
been expecting you basically my fondest
memories all come from the first half of
the game and rarely the second half
that's not to say that the second half
is bad I just don't think is a strong in
particular chapter 4 feels like the
weakest part of the game as the pacing
slows down quite a bit at this point in
the game I'm ready to fight Salazar and
escape the castle but oops ashley is
kidnapped a gun and Leia needs to trek
through the mine and make his way back
up there are great sequences in this
chapter like the minecart chase and 4 do
go but I can sort of take or leave the
rest dripping down chapter 4 could solve
this but I think there is potential in
moving these sections to after the
Salazar fight to help pacing or even
reworking them entirely there's a lot of
opportunity to improve this part of the
game and even out the pacing while
punching up set pieces to make it feel
as memorable as the earlier half playing
resin evil 4 for the first time back in
2007 yes it was the Wii version and yes
it's still one of the best versions of
the game don't at me I was surprised by
how often a game threw me off guard whoa
whoa whoa whoa you're throwing a
one-hit-kill chainsaw guy I mean the
first five minutes of the game wait
you're telling me if I shoot them in the
head instead of killing them they could
get even more [ __ ] up the dog comes
back and helps you oh my god this is the
greatest game ever made moments like
these felt special and memorable and
unfortunately they won't hit nearly the
same and a remake because I've already
experienced them which is why I'd love
it if the remake didn't adhere 100% of
the original and mix things up to create
new moments what if the chainsaw guy
didn't show in the opening but instead
is somewhere completely unexpected or
they had new enemy types that are
somehow even more terrifying than a
plague of busting
of a dudes head I'm not saying they need
to change everything but throw in enough
new surprises to help create new
memories for returning players a perfect
example of this would be the QuickTime
events for the record I think cuties are
a huge part of the identity of resonable
4 and I would like to see them stay in a
remake at their best they keep the
player on their toes with the potential
for one to happen at any moment if you
succeed you feel like a pro gamer and if
you mess up you get a ridiculous death
that's good for a laugh it's an element
of surprise that makes the QuickTime
events so good which is why it's emitted
ly easy to become bored of them on
repeat playthroughs of the game
so for remake what if they kept
QuickTime events but completely changed
when and how they happen this could all
be introduced via a remix mode that
changes up the variables for repeat
playthroughs if capcom wants to really
stay true to the original in the main
campaign last thing I want to touch on
is something that's near and dear to my
heart and that's the voice acting I sent
my right hand to be smaller than you
your right hand comes off because more
so than any other Resident Evil
I think resonable forest voice acting is
a key component to the game I think that
many lines in the game are even more
iconic than Jill sandwich curse everyone
going bingo for as annoying as Ashley
can be the specific way she yells will
forever be ingrained into my brain 4
also has the best version of Leon s
Kennedy or as my girlfriend called him
daddy Herbert he manages to be
simultaneously the coolest and dorkiest
video game protagonist with some
absolute cheeseball one-liners hasta
luego trying to recapture the magic of
old voice recording is next to
impossible Metal Gear Solid Twin Snakes
is an excellent example of that snake
hey you're that ninja if the other
resident evil' remakes are any
indication Capcom will probably want to
make enough changes to the script that
reusing these old recordings won't be
possible
heck they probably won't get the same
voice actors back Paul Mercier Leon's
voice actor in for hasn't done a voice
role since 2014 which is why I think
they should not even bother trying to
replicate that original magic and go
their own path with it I still want a
cheesy I want Salazar hamming it up and
Leone making lame jokes but if it was
just the same line for line I would be
constantly comparing it to the original
imagine that is an incredibly tall order
and I'm sure I'll still won't be fully
satisfied just because of how ingrained
in my brain rising before his dialogue
is but I do believe this would be the
best way to go about it except for the
merchant those are some of the best
videogame lines ever recorded and should
not be touched in any way is that old
stranger is that old stranger is that
old stranger is that old thank you I
could go on forever about all the small
things they could tweak like letting me
switch guns without opening the menu and
how they need to keep the fort in front
of the logo even though it makes a no
sense but I wanted to stick to broader
elements that I really care about so it
turned to you all in the comments to let
me know what you'd like to see in a
resident for remake and don't just say
nothing it's perfect come on I know
there's got to be something you want to
see improved and if you like this video
and my ideas let me know and if you did
like them you can also let me know sorry
to have bothered you I look forward to
returning to this video in several years
and seeing if any of this actually
panned out thanks for watching
[Music]